he calls himself bana and is in germany
for treatment
at the age of just seven he was forced
to become a child soldier in sierra
leone
to carry out killings he was given drugs
i feel good because i don't know what
i'm doing at that time i don't know what
i'm doing
i don't know what i'm doing
experts estimate a quarter of a million
children in 20 countries have been
forced to fight in military units
and not just in african countries but
increasingly in asia and the arab world
too
like in syria where reports say children
are being armed some with german-built
weapons
the international children's
organization tea de zom is calling for a
ban on the export of small arms to
countries outside the eu and nato
these countries can often be very
problematic and you can't control at all
how these weapons are going to be used
they're either handed over legally or
illegally and can end up in the hands of
children
children like bana
he says while he's physically now in
germany his soul is still back in sierra
leone reliving the trauma